les beaux jours arrivent ça sent l'été
et chacun espère un retour à une vie
normale mais avant cela il faudra
prendre quelques précautions
à compter de ce mercredi 9 juin le
gouvernement passe à la troisième étape
de son plan déconfinement avec la mise
en place du pass sanitaire le graal pour
accéder au rassemblement de plus de 1000
personnes à savoir et les concerts les
salons et les foires mais aussi les
matchs dans les stades les casinos ou
encore lé festival le transport aérien
et les croisières seront également
concernés mais attention beaucoup de
faits qui niveau circulent à ce sujet ce
n'est pas un passeport vaccination
plutôt le voir comme une sorte de
pochettes dans laquelle vous pourrez
glisser l'un de ces trois documents un
certificat de tests pcr un certificat de
vaccination ou encore un certificat de
rétablissement pour ceux qui ont déjà
attrapé le coc vide et ses certificats
présente et des qr codes et pourront
être stockés dans l'application tous
sentis co-lead développé par le
gouvernement et si vous n'avez pas de
smartphone pas de panique vous pourrez
également présenter ces documents sous
forme papier se passe sanitaire ne sera
pas nécessaire pour les moins de 11 ans
et surtout pas d'obligation d'avoir un
pass sanitaires pour accéder au lieu de
la vie quotidienne comme les restaurants
les cinémas les musées les parcs
d'attraction ou encore les grands
magasins
le pass sanitaire ne sera jamais un
droit d'accès qui différencie les
français il ne saurait être obligatoire
pour accéder au lieu de la vie de tous
les jours comme les restaurants théâtres
et cinémas ou pour aller chez des amis
par contre dans des lieux où se brassent
les foules comme les stades festivals
foires ou expositions il serait absurde
de ne pas l'utiliser
ce sera un outil supplémentaire pour
assurer la protection des français
le secrétaire d'état cdh rico lui
confirme que si un de ces établissements
impose la présentation du pass à son
entrée vous pourrez porter plainte et
mais du côté de l'opposition le pass
sanitaire fait grincer des dents
je m'inquiète de voir la société dans
laquelle on est en train de basculer
je m'inquiète de cette idée que
systématiquement pour avoir accès à des
loisirs où on seraient nombreux
nombreux il faudrait absolument recourir
à un document le pass sanitaire va être
réservé aux loisirs mais pour aller
bosser
y compris dans des situations où des
travailleuses et travailleurs prennent
des risques
on ne vous demandera pas le pass
sanitaires cette situation pourrait être
appelé à se renouveler avec d'autres
pandémies tirer le fil du passeport
sanitaire vous tomberez sur une société
de ségrégation selon l'état de santé et
sur l'eugénisme
tous les verrous sautron on met le doigt
dans un engrenage monstrueux 0 débat
éthique ni morale valider ça c'est
porter une immense responsabilité de son
côté la cnil gendarmes de la protection
des données personnelles dit être
favorable à ce passe sanitaire mais
demandent des garanties pour prévenir l
les dérives la cnil souligne que le
dispositif devra intégrer un certain
nombre de garanties afin de limiter
autant que possible la divulgation et la
conservation d'informations privées et
d'éviter tout risque de discrimination
en raison de l'état de santé mais
également en raison de la capacité
d'accès et d' usage des outils
numériques
en attendant le gouvernement tente de
rassurer comme il peut les plus
sceptiques
il ne s'agit pas de fliquer les gens de
montrer un pedigree de montrer dans la
durée qu'on est protégée contre le virus
mais de permettre de rouvrir des
événements qui sinon ne pourraient pas
se tenir dès le 26 juin c'est le passe à
lithaire européen qui devrait être mis
en place il sera commun aux 27 états
membres de l'union européenne